[Music]
welcome back to CBS this morning we're
following the latest on Hurricane
Florence as it nears makes landfall near
Wilmington North Carolina
the powerful category 1 hurricane is
lashing the coast with massive storm
surge and as Gail pointed out many
people may not know what a storm surge
is that is just rushing water coming in
very fast flood waters up to ten feet
deep are reported in New Bern North
Carolina hundreds of people have been
pulled from flooded homes and cars a
24-hour curfew is now in effect
firefighters rescued 70 people from a
hotel that sustained heavy damage in
Jacksonville North Carolina more than
300,000 customers are currently without
power in the Carolinas you know bianna
you mentioned the storm surge and The
Associated Press has one of these facts
that kind of reframes the way you think
about things we talked to mayor out law
in New Bern he said you know even even
he recognized some complacency in people
part of that was people heard category
two well that's not as bad as category
four and five category turns out the
wind speed is not the thing that causes
the the mayhem here from The Associated
Press 49 percent of us hurricane deaths
come from that storm surge only six
percent of the deaths come from or eight
percent of the deaths come from wind
so everybody focuses on the category
rightly so of course we in can knock
down trees and powerlines and all that
but the deaths come from the storm surge
and that rush of water and that's what's
caught up that last part of this 10 feet
high you understand that so in this
particular case don't pay close
attention to the category worried about
the storm surge now let's go right back
to the hurricane zone CBS Evening News
anchor Jeff Glor is leading our coverage
he's there in Wilmington North Carolina
Jeff good morning good morning Gail and
we are awaiting landfall here in
Wilmington North Carolina it's been so
difficult to figure out exactly when it
actually does make landfall because this
storm has been moving so slowly offshore
and because of that as you mentioned
John makes a great point it is not just
the wind and the wind is obviously very
bad here right now the rain is coming
sideways down and up
but it is that storm surge and it's the
flooding and it's it's not just the
surge and the flooding it's the people
attempting to drive into the water
specifically that typically can cause
most of the injuries and and
unfortunately deaths in hurricanes like
this and in some cases because that
water comes up so quickly here in
Wilmington it started getting real bad
just after midnight it's gotten
progressively worse as the morning has
gone on here and again what we're ready
for again we're in an open clear area as
safe as you can be we do have shelter
right nearby as safe as you can be in
this spot if it gets to a point where we
need to go inside we will do that but
we've been watching what's happening
here and the issue again for everyone
along the coast is the length of this
storm I think they're talking about at
least two to four feet of a storm surge
here in Wilmington if not more others
have dealt with far worse at this point
and when and that's when it comes up so
fast
again landfall approaching here we've
gotten some of the worst of the winds if
it hits us makes landfall right here we
should get an area of relative calm for
a little bit there when we're in the
middle of the eye and then it gets bad
once again guys back to you in studio it
hasn't even hit landfall yet Jeff please
be careful here three days yeah yeah we
mean that we want the story but we also
want you